good morning John here in America it is
the day after Thanksgiving which means
that it is black right Hank it's Twitter
its Twitter I have a question what
what's your most controversial opinion
oh come on Twitter why would I tell you
that content man its content it's easy
format to put your own personal spin on
without having to come up with something
fresh yeah no yeah that makes sense but
look my most controversial opinions are
pretty controversial and they're also
like nuanced and take a long time to
explain how do you make everything so
complicated you're just supposed to say
something dumb that everybody's gonna be
mad about like Indian food is bad and
everyone knows it well why would anyone
say that like even if I don't like
Indian food I recognize that some people
must write what's the punch of make
people mad yeah you're right engaging
I'm leaving you to the water here but I
can't make you drink you just have to
come up with something dumb that 80 to
90% of people are gonna despise but then
10 to 20% of people will be on your side
and they will have your back and that's
gonna keep the conversation going oh my
god like this seems complicated no one
said any of this was easy baby your job
is to make it look easy well actually I
think it is what it's easy but is legs
what but is legs that's ludicrous but is
but but is but but but is also legs but
is but but is legs that's I mean the
dumbest thing I've ever heard
look your leg bone is in your book but
you only have one but I know that's what
makes this such an interesting sentence
it's grammatically confusing because you
have a singular but but plural legs but
this isn't a grammatical question it's
an anatomical one and but is leg but
scientifically anatomically your gut is
in your torso and your gut ends in your
butthole which is your butt so but is
torso right the butthole is not legs the
butthole is not put the blood hole is
not blunt it's in the name of the butt
transitions - but hold
just as hand is not arm arm transitions
into hey okay so hand is not arm then
shoulder is not arm then but is not legs
shoulder is arm don't say it and but is
legs
oh god okay look I can't tell you why
but you are obviously wrong you told me
to have a controversial opinion why are
you yelling at me for having one oh my
god I did didn't I
like I had legitimate I had forgotten
good good work Twitter this is the world
that we have chosen for ourselves
you got any others all right second
controversial opinion Black Friday is
Joe my first book an absolutely
remarkable thing was picked as a Black
Friday deal by audible and United
Kingdom so this week into the UK it's
only three pounds also I have a book
coming out July 7th 2020 a beautifully
foolish endeavor I can't believe I did
it but I did it and lots of links to
pre-order that and also get a quick
synopsis in the description I'll be
talking more about it soon and right now
through Monday there's free shipping
everywhere in the world for all orders
over $50 at dftba.com we have lots of
amazing new Black Friday products I'm
wearing many of our and pins that are
coming out right now including this
denture karolius pen from journey to the
micro cosmetic and also because we did a
pizza jump bandana this year now we are
also doing a handkerchief look I don't
expect to sell a lot of them but we had
to make the Joe servo today of TV a calm
right now
this entire video is set up for a Black
Friday promotion controversial opinion
yeah man but is legs John I'll see you
on Tuesday